Christopher is more than a rhetorician
he does have to do that thing this is
one of the reasons I admire him he has
to do that thing called work where you
actually have to find out facts you have
to brutal around and you have to get
them right because the cost of getting
them wrong is enormous especially in
America it's a lawsuit it's a lawsuit
that can ruin you and the side of
Christopher that perhaps people don't
understand because it's the side they
naturally never see they see
um they see the the famous slightly
shambling Drinker and smoker who adorned
so many platforms and made so many
debates and and what's so extraordinary
in his ability to speak perfectly
without notes so absolutely unbeatable
in debate possibly the greatest debater
since demosthenes
and what what the dentist is is the man
alone in his Library um of the man
chasing sources the man making sure that
every word he writes is not only
beautifully written but is beautifully
researched and and that is that is why
books like the Kissinger books still
bear reading time and time again because
they're kind of unarguable
amongst the causes for which he is known
there is one perhaps which Springs most
readily to people's lips
um and that is
um that is if you like the he noticed
before many of us did that the tide of
the Enlightenment was being rolled back
quite deliberately and so he is very
well known for amongst other things he's
extraordinary but God Is Not Great our
religion poisons everything and perhaps
the best known
um uh even better known than Christopher
for such a thing is the Emeritus
Professor for the understanding of
science from Oxford University who let
us not forget it is one of the great
evolutionary biologists of his day and
I'm about to introduce him on stage now
Professor Richard Dawkins
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well Richard in a sense would it be fair
to say that
your anger at religion is not so much
the prime cause of your life it's just
simply that you found it was getting in
the way of of of a free education of of
free thinking
yes I I think my my anger probably like
Christopher's is somewhat exaggerated
and it's exaggerated because people who
are very devoted to religion uh when
they hear any kind of criticism however
Mild they think it's angry I think the
reason is they're so unused to it uh
that even if relatively mild criticism a
criticism that would sound mild if it
was a criticism of a piece of theater or
a restaurant or something if it's
religion it sounds angry
um so I think that's exaggerated
he
I suppose is angry because he sees the
tyrannical God figure as a sort of
dictator a kind of
um
North Korea
um this horror figure so it's on the
peace with his political thinking I'm
sort of guessing there whereas in my
case I think it's sort of educational I
I feel that the subversion of young
minds teaching them the the second race
explanation for the existence of
themselves and the universe as opposed
to the real one given that the real one
is so enthralling and fascinating
um it just uh so tortry and so second
rate to fob them off with
supernaturalism so that that if to the
extent that I am angry that's probably
the main source of it yeah surprisingly
I think it was Yasser Arafat who said
that the history of most of the wars of
the world is quarrels over whose
invisible friend was more powerful
I suppose you will continue to get hate
mail I know Christopher has had the
weird experience of having to design
which is weirder the the people who are
praying for him
um not not necessarily even to get
better but to find Faith
um in his moment of of physical illness
or those who are gloating that he will
Rose to Eternity in hell
I think they're about to equal yeah in
numbers aren't they I wonder whether
when they say I'll pray for you he gives
that wonderful reply I'll think for you
yes
brilliant